los candidatos tenían hasta el lunes
para presentar su candidatura ante la
justicia electoral para presidente son
12 candidatos otros 8 pretendientes ya
habían desistido en las últimas semanas
como por ejemplo el ex juez sergio moro
o el ex gobernador de san pablo sund
ahora lo que refuerza la polarización
entre los dos grandes favoritos el ex
presidente luiz inácio lula da silva del
partido de los trabajadores y el
mandatario de extrema derecha james
bolsonaro según la última encuesta de
opinión lula tiene una ventaja de 12
puntos con 44 por ciento de las
intenciones de voto
pero esa diferencia es cada vez menor
revolucionario crece entre los más
vulnerables que se beneficiaron del
aumento del subsidio llamado auxilio
brasil decidido hace poco por el
presidente y aprobado por el congreso
lula organizó su primer evento este
martes en son bandas del campo es donde
en la zona industrial de san pablo es
donde inició su militancia como
sindicalista
el revolucionario ha decidido organizar
su primer evento de campaña en ruiz de
force a la ciudad donde fue apuñalado
hace cuatro años a un poco menos de un
mes de las elecciones la campaña se abre
en un clima tenso y de polarización y
también es importante destacar que
preocupan los repetidos ataques del
presidente
al sistema electoral
suscitan el temor de que revolucionaron
pueda impugnar el resultado en caso de
derrota